today on stick to football we are gonna
have a damn good time because we're just
jumping right into it a two-round mock
draft all three host myself Matt Miller
Melo Connor Rogers you can check it out
on Bleacher Report's youtube page you
listen to it hopefully that's what
you're doing right now let's to it on a
podcast stitcher Spotify fellas we're
just jumping right in there's nothing to
talk about the NFL didn't release cop
picks CBA is to a vote and in combine
ratings were only up three percent so
thank you for taking 18 years off my
life for 3% ratings boost and I fell
appreciate it
on the clock let's just go number one
Cincinnati Bengals Melo was kind enough
to give me the first pick in the draft
and I'll get this one right you all want
to [ __ ] on my mock drafts we're gonna
get this one right Joe borough number
one overall to the Cincinnati Bengals
we've been saying it since December I
feel like is since the draft order was
known I don't I don't need to over
explain this I don't need to overthink
it borough is gonna end up one of the
top rated quarterbacks that I've
evaluated in my 10 years of doing this
and the Bengals need a quarterback
boom BAM and I'm a number two I agree
with you I think that's easy on the bang
Thank You number two with the Washington
Redskins there is some smoke here with
the to a tongue of Iola stuff I'm not
buying into it yet I think that they're
gonna look at these two picks and say we
have chase young we have 2a but we also
kind of have Haskins and we might be
happy with him I think this year they're
gonna roll with Haskins and take chase
young he doesn't really feel a need that
they have there I think they're all set
edge rusher this is a guy once in a
generation
almost he's one of the best pass rushers
that we've seen in a while and you look
at a difference-maker like nick Bosa
last year I think that Chase young is
gonna come in and have that same impact
as rookie so I think that's just gonna
be too much for the Redskins to pass up
they go chase young here shameless plug
scouting no but Friday morning I wrote
about that if the buzz is real or not
to it of the Redskins so there you go
synthetic and we won't give it away here
number three the Detroit save it got to
read it number three the Detroit Lions
we're still not doing trades and our
mock drafts yet and if the Lions stay
pat here I think the pick has to be Jeff
Okuda you look at how all those defenses
were built with map attrition New
England it was through having a shutdown
number one corner I know they have
various sleigh I don't know how much
longer he's going to be there I also
know that Jeff Okuda is the best corner
prospect I've ever watched since I've
been doing this in round around 2014 so
this is a no-brainer for me absolutely
lava CUDA and think he upgrades the
Lions defense tremendously from day one
now the draft gets fun
because like Connor said no trades I
think we would have all projected the
Miami Dolphins to trade up to number
three to get a quarterback but now the
draft gets interesting at number four
overall the New York Giants I was
incredibly torn on this selection isaiah
simmons is a rare defensive prospect i
feel like he's a bigger version of
Derwin james like a bigger more
versatile Derwin James do you take a guy
like that or do you try to protect
Daniel Jones or excuse me do you try to
protect the quarterback and the running
back as Joe judge says it you want to
say their [ __ ] names I will say this
guy's name Jedrek wills is still the top
tackle on this draft I know Makai Becton
had a great combine I know Tristan
wharfs I actually had a record-setting
combine that's all well and good but
when it comes to just blocking people
moving individuals Jedrek wills is still
the best in this class so I'm gonna give
him to the Giants here he's gonna play
left tackle I wouldn't be surprised if
Nate's older gets flipped to the right
side or if they just cut him and signed
Jack Conklin and just say you know what
problem solved on the o-line let's go
get it
I talked to a huge Giants fan today
actually and he was telling me how
important he thinks it is for this
franchise to protect say Kwan Barclay
and I said Cole do you mean protect
Daniel Jones and he says no I don't care
about him we got to protect say Kwan
Barclay and I think he's probably right
you need some offensive lineman in there
you guys didn't ask the Giants fan as a
ten-year-old next up number five overall
the Miami Dolphins they've been waiting
for this all year I don't think we
needed to talk about it too much if tua
is there they're going to take him and I
think we all three kind of predict
they're going to move up to take him so
if he's there at number five yeah it's
happening alright number six for the
Chargers I mean for me this is just they
need a tackle so bad if you looked at
who's penciled in to start for them
right now after their big trade I think
they won that trade I like Trey Turner I
think he's a great get for them at guard
I don't I'm very torn on what they do
here if they take Justin Herbert or if
they upgrade the tackle spot
I would rather upgrade the tackle spot
I'm going with Tristan Dwarfs I think he
had a phenomenal combine he's a great
prospect when you look at how this
draught stacks up at tackle it's wills
and then it's worse and for the Chargers
they're starting to build a foundation
in place on that offensive line so when
they do have a young quarterback step in
there and play he'll be protected pretty
well and I want to say I'm gonna I'm
gonna jump in on some your guys picks
but I don't think this is crazy I know a
lot of fans are gonna be upset like why
are they not drafting a quarterback here
and my honestly when I saw you do this
today I was like what I wasn't gonna
quarterback here I would not be
surprised if they go the route of a Cam
Newton or a stop-gap quarterback for you
they have no timers no tackles now I'm a
trade and russello Koon they got that's
a hell of a trade for the Chargers you
got a 25 year old law pro guard for a 32
year old washed-up left tackle it's
pretty good trade all the way around for
the Chargers so getting tristan where if
you put him in at left tackle but again
i wouldn't be surprised if Cam Newton's
their quarterback and we'll see what
they do in round 2 here you gotta sell
tickets in LA and cam would do exactly
that's my thing here I saw when they
trade it with the Panthers I was like
why didn't you just try to get Cam
Newton while you were at it but you're
waiting to see if he's healthy I am up
now number 7 the Carolina Panthers
quarterbacks are on the board here
Justin Herbert is available join loves
available and I thought about it but I
have been saying for a while and I'm not
moving off my spot on this the Panthers
are trying to tank for Trevor Lawrence I
firmly believe this is happening I think
trading trade Turner even points to this
a little bit more you're trying to get
those you know assets where Russell o
Kuhn that's like an an older guy let's
lose some games I think we could see
this roster get pillaged for draft picks
Derrick brown though can be your
foundation piece on defense while you're
waiting for that quarterback there's
gonna be a lot of discussion about
Derrick brown easy a good enough pass
rusher to be drafted in the top ten
picks
I even wonder this myself sometimes but
I have seen him just wreak havoc playing
nose tackle demanding a triple team at
times you're gonna free up Brian burns
you're gonna free up the rest of that D
line if you don't make plays so I like
Derek Brown here at seven do you think
that they're a candidate to move down
and kind of start
I'll draft picks for next year like if
somebody boarded to move up to seven and
draft one of these I definitely think so
so in this scenario like if you're the
Raiders Colts whomever Patriots I want a
quarterback
I think Carolina is a definitely team
that I would be calling awesome number
eight the Arizona Cardinals I think
everybody knows that they need some
offensive line help I'm not gonna go in
that direction you guys just took wills
you took worse that leaves me with Makai
Becton Andrew Thomas Josh Jones I'm not
in love with any of those guys and I
think that Kyler Murray is gonna climb
up to the ear of Kliff Kingsbury and say
go get my guy CD lamp we need another
receiver I think that CD can be that
number one target that they need Larry
Fitzgerald is great first about Hall of
Famer one of the best receivers I've
ever seen he's old though and they need
somebody in there so I actually think
that they're gonna pull the trigger on
CD you might say why would they go after
receiver why would they go after a
quarterback last year fair enough for
ninety fair enough number nine in
Jacksonville Jaguars see em go Makai
Becton this is a team that desperately
once again needs help on the offensive
line how many times you're gonna hear
that in the top ten over and over again
well the answer is until they're all off
the board that's how so when I look at
Jacksonville you have Gardner Minshew
there
you do need to start protecting these
quarterbacks you really do and this pick
came down to Andrew Thomas and Makai
Becton Jacksonville is enough assets
where with the other first rounder and
their second round pick they can start
to replenish all these holes they have
on defense but right now in the top ten
before that well dries up you need to
land one of these tackles and I think
somebody like Becton who's a really
really impressive run blocker for
Leonard fournette is just they must have
in this spot for them Leonard fournette
tweet the Will Smith thing with his face
is so great absolutely amazing I think
he might be out of there before the
season started I was gonna say who would
be shocked if he's next yeah at all
number 10 the Cleveland Browns the run
oh tackles is gonna stop here because
the last one that's worthy of a top ten
pick is coming off the board that's
Andrew Thomas he and his 35 inch arms
going to the Cleveland Browns I was
talking to a scout this week for the the
piece on tua and the buzz and he said
you know it's crazy outside like
three to ten we feel like there's some
fluctuation like if there's a little bit
of confusion about what could happen but
the one thing we all feel great about is
that the Browns will draft the left
tackle and I agree I think I think you
can just go best left tack on the board
boom go to the Cleveland Browns now I
say that Simmons is still on the board
in our mock draft which I think would
make would make it interesting of do you
draft a really really unique piece on
defense or do you go with the left
tackle I think a team that is being
guided by analytics will look at that
and say the value of the position is so
great at left tackle you have to go that
even with Simmons on the board so that's
why I want Andrew Thomas Joe Schobert
sleeving
I say a similar to be amazing to fill
his spot but they have to protect Baker
Mayfield yeah I think this draft shakes
out very well for Cleveland number 11
overall the New York Jets we just talked
about how all the offensive linemen are
gone I think they're gonna go need to
get some offensive weapons here you're
probably losing Robbie Anderson and I'll
let Connor kind of chime in here but I
think they're gonna go with Jerry Judy
if Jerry Judy falls here at 11 they
could go chase on an edge rusher but I
think with Jerry Judy's still on the
board you get a chance to get a real
playmaker to put in that offense and to
help Sam darn 'old I couldn't pass up
the opportunity yeah you can't you're
after what's not there right I mean if
there are no tackles that they have
created in that spot it probably comes
down to somebody like Judy Henry rugs
because of his speed and maybe even a
guy like Kayla Vaughn chase on if they
don't look down on offense
so I don't mean interrupt you guys as
we're recording Dinah Rossini reported
that the Redskins are gonna allow Trent
Williams to seek a trade that might be
the Jets answer left tackle yeah I mean
it or the Browns answer or there's a lot
of teams that guy they need an answer at
right tackle to is what the problem is
though the buck doesn't stop there 12
the Las Vegas Raiders this is where
Isiah Simmons comes off the board and
man you got to be feeling good if you're
the Las Vegas Raiders and this one
happens because I think if you want them
you'll have to trade up for them but
we've seen linebackers fall in the past
this man is not just the linebacker
though we've seen him play all over the
field I will not I was just telling our
guy Adam left go when I went on the left
go show that there is no player
comparison for him when you look at
build you might go to camp Chancellor
and you're like well he ran a lot better
than cam
he's heavier than cam Matt you called
him a bigger Derwin James yeah that's
right because he's a lot bigger than
Derwin James so it's very and faster I
don't know how to even explain it at
this point but I'll say this for the
Raiders that is one damn good football
player they'd be getting in the middle
of their defense if you have to stop
Travis Kelce and Patrick mahomes it's
kind of the guy you want to do it but
that's a great place to start it yeah
like that's where you want and you get
Jonathan Abram back healthy not not bad
I think he fits that mold of what we saw
last year they want guys that are gonna
come in and win it's like they're just
acquiring these alpha dogs in the locker
room and I think Isaiah Simmons would
fit in with those other guys very well
if he's there at 12 I will be pissed off
Chiefs fans ever will be very pissed off
number 13 the Indianapolis Colts
Justin Herbert's on the board Jordan
Love is on the board I'm not taking a
quarterback and I want Colts fans to
listen before you turn this off you have
Jacoby Brissette and I know y'all don't
love him but that locker room does and
that matters you're also the favorite to
bring in Phillip Rivers
if you sign Phillip Rivers and you have
Jacoby Brissette you're not drafting a
quarterback in the first round guys it's
just not gonna happen
you're probably not drafted a
quarterback in the second round with
Phillip Rivers and Jacoby burr set so
I'm going with Caleb on chase on one
thing this team lacks pass-rush
they've tried bringing in Justin Houston
they've tried drafting guys in the
second third fourth round just not
finding that piece chase on is that
answer I've compared him to Josh Allen
came out of Kentucky last year was
amazing for the Jacksonville Jaguars he
can rush he stopped the run he could
drive back in coverage they chase on
when you pair him with what they already
have on defense that's starting to look
really really special yeah I mean he
fits in immediately with them number 14
overall the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
quarterbacks are still there Bruce
Arians doesn't love Jameis and I'm not
gonna predict the free agency signings
here I think Teddy Bridgewater's names
been out there a lot recently I think
they're gonna draft Justin Herbert this
is a big tall guy pretty strong arm I
think that Bruce Arians is going to look
at him and say yep he can win in my
offense I can keep this guy from
throwing 30 interceptions let's go ahead
and pull the trigger
especially if they don't have to trade
up in our fake draft scenario no I was
gonna say can we just add in like Justin
Herbert's gonna go before 14 jordan
loves probably to go before 14 but be
for free agency it is incredibly hard to
slot these guys in because like the the
Chargers the Panthers it's just
impossible than all right now the Colts
which of these teams will be
good-looking at quarterback yeah it is I
mean we're inching closer to where
trades will be on the table here I think
post free agency that is when you start
getting into that though and how
realistic it is so number 15 this is one
team that would have been in around the
league so we're gonna talk about it here
the Broncos acquire AJ boy yay from
Jacksonville this is essentially guys
they're taking on his salary is what
this comes down to here I think he fits
Fangio scheme perfectly so for the
Broncos here you know as we hear the
rumblings they're gonna let Chris Harris
walk there's been times where maybe CJ
Henderson or Christian Folden might be
in the conversation at this pick but
after acquiring an outside man coverage
corner I think they got to be feeling
good about that trade what did you guys
think of it I liked it just I mean I
hate that they're gonna lose Chris
Harris jr. that could be that could
really benefit Melos team but I like boy
I think he's a good player there's a
recent a couple years ago for agency he
got paid and for the Broncos this just
helps fill one need where you probably
would have considered CJ Henderson at
this pick at 15 overall but because of
that like okay well now we can move on
to other nice whether it's left tackle a
wide receiver to a defensive lineman
they actually have a lot of needs so I
like that just to get established guys
so we're gonna fit in that defensive
scheme yeah in for Jacksonville you're
just kind of turning over the locker
room you're in a rebuild there I think
after Minshew kind of started to have
some success last year they just said
you know what we have to get rid of some
pieces let's get rid of some of these
guys that are making money we'll try to
win and rebuild through the draft so
that's what they're doing no doubt so to
that pick for the Broncos I'm going once
you bought and Kinlaw here this is a
team that could use some interior
defensive line help Kinlaw is an
absolute wrecking ball I think he might
even have a higher ceiling then Derrick
brown when I watch Kinlaw as a pass
rusher so I really like this pick for
them I think he's just starting to reach
his potential and he had a really really
good draft process once again the
Broncos they're gonna load up on defense
I think another pick in consideration
here could have been Josh Jones if
they're looking at tackle but maybe
they'll get you know active in fridge
see and look at the Jack Conklin market
or one of these trades like you
mentioned Trent Williams so that's
another way that could shake out for
them but there is no question about it
Siobhan Kinlaw on that defensive line
with Von Miller and Bradley Chubb that
is a nasty nasty front for Vic Fangio
yeah and he pits Fangio's defense really
well Vic who was in San Francisco Eric
Armstead to force Buckner those tall
guys who could play defensive in who can
kick inside play defensive tackle on
passing downs kianlawl definitely fits
that last pick before our first break
number 16 the Atlanta Falcons
this was actually a very difficult
selection for me I thought about going G
Andre Swift here just because the way
the board fells like I think Devon chief
Raymond's gonna be a cap casualty let's
get a stud running back in here and I
really also I mean I thought about going
D line but I just did not like the value
so I was CJ Henderson at this spot
instead they focus so much on often /t
the offensive line to first-round picks
I want to go to that secondary continue
to get younger I know they've drafted
some dudes there but I look at Henderson
I see a number one corner in the NFL
he's big he is incredibly fast so he and
pair him with Isaiah Oliver you already
have a good slot corner at Kendall
Sheffield he drafted last year and as
Trufant who was drafted now seven or
eight years ago he starts to get to that
into his career you just slide CJ
Henderson right in there at that corner
spot yeah I love that pick and I see Jay
Henderson's been my corner one corner
too for a very long time until a coup to
finally past him so I love what you're
doing there Matt what's up guys we are
back here running through our two round
mock draft pick number 17 I'm up with
the Dallas Cowboys there are a lot of
good players still available on the
board here I'm going to assume they're
bringing back Amari Cooper this year
which means I'm going secondary with
this pick I'm going to Xavier McKinney
it's been mocked there and a lot of
different picks a lot of different
drafts but I like his playmaking ability
in the secondary and they're gonna have
to do something in that secondary to
stay competitive on the defensive side
of the ball I think this is one of the
best members that's still kind of
somehow going under the radar I think
he's almost established himself now a
safety one in most MOX
I like him and a lot of corners aren't
available I don't like it there Henry
rug's is probably the only other guy
that I would consider there right now
yeah both defensive lineman gone so that
would have been in consideration for
them so I think getting what is
considered the top safety makes a lot of
sense for Dallas 18 the Miami Dolphins
listen if you go draft 2a you better
have a plan in place to protect the guy
and Josh Jones did exactly that this
season in college football you know I
don't Matt you've compared him to Andre
Dillard before a few times I really like
that I think Jones has light feet he's
very smooth and pass Pro was actually
pretty impressed how he gets out in
space as a run blocker and four screens
so Jones surprisingly we talked about
the top four tackles a lot but Jones is
sneakily not there's not a crazy gap I
think when you go from four to five I
really like his film yeah he's a good
player and I think with two a one thing
we have like we've spent so much time
like uh to his injury history - it takes
a lot of hits I mean that dude will
string a play out waiting for something
to happen and get just I mean the injury
the Mississippi State game is one of
those so I think with - you've got to
protect him with a Josh Jones number 19
the Las Vegas Raiders they guys say
Simmons earlier
buckle up this is now the fastest team
in the NFL they're getting Henry rugs at
19 I don't personally think rugs will
fall this far when the actual draft
comes but again pre free agency things
are still a little bit murky rugs is a
special type of player I mean he's he's
a deep threat who doesn't even have to
run long routes it's an amazing thing
we've compared his play to Tyreke ill
it's just not very many people who are
that fast but who are also good at
football there are there people who were
that fast but also being a good football
player it's just an added bonus this is
not John Ross I think you're getting a
well-rounded athlete run after catch is
amazing field visions very very good and
I think he automatically tapes takes the
top off any defense he faces
John Ross caught 4,000 yards last year
but whatever oh no I'm singing John
Brown's like what I took the because I
thought you're going after my Pitt State
guy no he's definitely not John he hopes
he's John Brown I said a league
number 20 overall the Jacksonville
Jaguars I'm back on track now I got my
blood boiling I'm good though the
Jaguars already took an offensive tackle
in the first pick with number 9 overall
with makai Becton so looking at their
needs now you could go linebacker corner
and Patrick Queen is still sitting
I think that he's an elite linebacker
you look at the three linebackers I know
a lot of times we lump Queen and Marie
together but there are three very good
linebackers one just maybe play safety
too but Patrick Queen his ability to run
sideline to sideline drive back in
coverage I think that he's going to
establish himself as one of these top 20
picks right now he's at the Jaguars at
20 I think that he immediately comes in
established this up as that Mike
linebacker and can help lead this
defense and help Reed build this defense
to what they used to be 21 Philadelphia
Eagles you guys know how badly they
needed wide receiver helped this year it
felt like they were running a - tight
end offense is the focal point I go at
Justin Jefferson here he seems like a
first-round lock after a phenomenal
combine four four three official 37 and
a half vertical jump he's got sighs got
a good catch radius I think he does a
lot after the catch I love Justin
Jefferson in this class I'll tell you in
a lot of wide-receiver classes he might
even be in consideration for the top guy
but when you're playing with Jerry Judy
CD lamb Henry rocks all in the same
receiver class it's a tough go but for
the Eagles this guy would have an impact
on that offense a tremendous impact on
that offense right away with Carson
Wentz number 22 another team that needs
a wide receiver the Buffalo Bills and
one thing that I think this Draft Falls
very well for them because they need
size they want someone who can extend
the catch radius for Josh Allen who
loves Josh not always the most accurate
guy let's give them t Higgins who I
still think it's one of the best
vertical receivers in this draft
stretches the field he's great above the
turf watch him dominate in the red zone
I think that's exactly what the bills
need didn't see him do anything in the
combine my man said he was resting which
I respect that he didn't lie wild wild
excuse you know what our season ended
three weeks ago I'm chilling like I'm
just hanging out I respect that from t
Hagan sock can't fall if you know the
receivers have been pretty good in the
NFL - yeah there's a couple of them I
think if memory serves me right
number 23 overall the New England
Patriots I think that they're sitting
here with actually more needs than what
we think usually for the Patriots but
I'm just going to give them a defensive
weapon I'm looking at eater gross may
doze and he reminds me a lot of that
Jones guy that used to come off the edge
for the
I think that Bella check will see this
he'll look at the tape and he's gonna
say yeah I can use this guy in my
defense he can get after the quarterback
right now he's just gonna be one of
those guys that comes in has 8 to 12
sacks every year and is just consistent
and it maybe gets up there and can help
lead the league or the AFC in sacks I
have heard it at his stock is
skyrocketing after interviews like that
he might not be here at 23 yeah I love
him we had Brian burns last year kind of
shoot up the board and I think that
gross tomatoes can do the same in the
last couple weeks to the draft 20 for
the New Orleans Saints this is where
Christian Fulton doesn't have to move
very far guys go to LSU and then go down
and play for the Saints
listen full and I say it over and over
again when he's healthy he's a different
player I know there's a lot of film out
there where people are like he's getting
smoked by Henry rug she's getting smoked
here I think he plays through injuries I
think he's a really tough player I think
you saw the speed and even the six nine
four three cone at the combine guys just
really really good stuff all around for
him in a corner class that's actually
pretty decent I mean there are a lot of
good players that corner in this class
that'll go in the top fifty but for the
Saints getting a number two guy and
falling might put that defense over the
top and they desperately need that in
pass coverage right now yeah I do what
ask did you consider going quarterback
here because I've had this happen drafts
and I've thought like met Jordan Love
makes a lot of sense for them I'm glad
you brought it up I thought about Jordan
love here but I'll say this we are on
the last leg with Drew Brees here and I
think you have to be doing everything
you can to win now and Jordan love is
the exact opposite of that so I looked
at it and said they can use a number to
corner Fulton can play right away he's
got reps against NFL guys in the SEC for
a couple years now I mean you look at
now Andrews P in free agency might
dictate a little bit what they do on the
offensive line I just think the Saints
got a double down if you're bringing
drew brees back you're getting an impact
player in round one this year yeah no I
just I know people are gonna ask so I
gotta throw it out there number 25 the
Minnesota Vikings I thought about a
quarterback here
Kirk Cousins one year left on his
contract but in a similar vein I feel
like this team is trying to win now I
mean they they made it through the
playoffs and
I was talking to some Vikings fans in
India at the combine and they thought
man they thought they had a chance
against the Niners you didn't and here's
why Riley Reef is your left tackle so
let's solve that problem Austin Jackson
from USC comes in a player who is a
little bit controversial
I think the Iowa game in the bowl game
did not look great the rest of year look
phenomenal he's an athlete he does need
to add some power needs to work on that
inside shoulder but when I look at guys
who pass the eyeball test in Scouting we
call on the hoof Austin Jackson's a left
tackle on the hoof I mean he looks like
one he moves like one just has to work a
little bit on some of his technical
deficiencies but I think he profiles
really well as a starting left tackle in
the NFL yeah the sixth offensive tackle
we have going here in the first round I
don't know if that's a record but I mean
it's got to be close I would think
number 26 overall the Miami Dolphins
this team already took their left tackle
they already took their quarterback I'm
gonna go with running back here I know
that they should probably address that
defensive side of the ball too because I
hear it's important but DeAndre Swift is
a game changer this and we did our top
five game changes and Matt you put him
there I really think that he can help
take over the game help out this young
quarterback you're gonna have to help
out of young offensive line get DeAndre
swift the ball he can catch the ball he
can run his vision his balance is great
can he carry the load I don't know but I
think he's gonna get the chance in Miami
it just makes too much sense here in the
first round of the first team to grab a
running back Dolphins fans you me mad at
you cuz I deal with this once a month
when I do mock drafts did you give any
thought to because we're doing at around
Mach today they pick again at 39 I know
that's not your pick but did you give
any thought to ah let's go another
position here let's go corner let's go
yeah and yes Gator running back at 39
right but what other positions you need
to go you're gonna go edge I don't love
epinet
I don't love some of those other guys
that are sitting there I think that
maybe you say well we had a really good
safety in when we let him walk maybe
Grant Delpit who's still on the board
for us I I think that this is a rare
opportunity we're at pick number 26 you
get a guy that can probably be a top 10
rusher in the NFL we saw last year with
Josh Jacobs going late in the first
round you can get a very good running
back I know that say Quan went number
two overall but you can get similar
production here with DeAndre swift but
it picked number 26
whereas you know you're not taking a
chance on one
these edge rushers that are the last at
the position yeah I think Swift's
ceiling as a pass catcher is just
tremendous to the point where if you're
taking someone like to uh you know you
you better have someone like that I
don't think you're just like Jonathan
Taylor I think my only concern would be
with him why have him just a little
behind Swift is that ceiling as a pass
catcher so I like that pick for Miami
I guess the fans won't but I really do
twenty seven the Seattle Seahawks tell
me if you've heard this before they need
some help on the offensive line again
these are releases but yeah every been
saying this since we started this show
and somehow they still make the playoffs
and have great years the time and time
again Russell Wilson's amazing
Cesar Ruiz is such an easy pick here for
me because he can play guard he can play
Center he did phenomenal work at center
this year but when you're six for three
twenty and you move like he does you can
use a tremendous guard prospect as well
so I think the versatility really comes
into play here day one starter potential
with Ruiz and for Seattle not having to
move to get a day one starter on the
offensive line that can help as
especially in the run game for them I
mean that's pretty tremendous and we
know how much John Schneider likes to
move around the board but this time he
doesn't have to I would have drafted him
at thirty-one had he been there I would
have bet thirty-two that's how much I
like him number 28 the Baltimore Ravens
Matt Jew Don's a free agent Michael
Pierce the free agent they're gonna need
some help in the front seven I've very
much considered Kenneth Murray here the
middle linebacker but I think pass
arashi's King for the Ravens they
believe they're gonna play with a lead a
lot you want to go get the quarterback
so AJ epinet calling it a fall I really
think this is just about where he's
gonna come off the board in this 25 to
35 range so the Ravens get a player I
believe is a plug-and-play starter he's
just very scheme specific it I was glad
to see came in at 65 275 they asked a
good sign for him but just know who he
is and I know Melo has said before he
might be Solomon Thomas you could be
right I think there's definitely times
where you watch him playing you just
want more out of him then there are
times he plays USC and he looks like he
looks like the best player in college
football so he might be Mathieu Don
might be yeah like that might be his
best game fit all right I'm up number 29
overall
the Tennessee Titans this whole roster
just kind of depends on what happens at
quarterback and running back they could
have two new guys there they could have
Tom Brady they could bring back Derrick
Henry a lot of what-ifs going on so I'm
looking at it like maybe we move on from
Derrick Henry the guy wants a lot of
money they might go into the April
drafts and say man we can't pay this guy
he's probably gonna sit out for the year
if we would have stay atop of the AFC
like we were last year we're gonna need
somebody to come in here in total Rock
and nobody did that better than Jonathan
Taylor in college football he has proven
time after time three years running that
he can carry the load that he can come
in there and run with power they can
catch the ball out of the backfield
blazing fast in the 40 I think the
fumble issues we can fix those Adrian
Peterson came into the NFL had really
bad fumbling issues they fixed it Tiki
Barber with carrying the ball
differently I think that they can look
at Jonathan Taylor and say yeah this is
the guy that can carry the load and help
us stay atop of the air if he would just
go down some he would have less fumbles
yeah that's a give and take but just go
down and that's sometimes that takes the
NFL for guys to learn that like know
when you are stopped in college football
you can run through something that goes
those guys they might have you wrapped
up but you still keep training those
legs and you break free you don't see
that a lot in the NFL so and I do think
that players start to worry about
longevity and they say oh I got to
preserve this stuff for a long career
I'm gonna go down in this situation
which will help reduce fumbles as well
here's my question for you guys do you
think Jonathan Taylor is an upgrade over
Derrick Henry I do actually I know
people will hear that and like gasp that
I'm in asking the question well I think
I mean when you when you factor
everything is so just is he a better
player probably not right now if we're
looking at the last 18 games but you
can't just think of it that way because
salary matters we're in ter matters I
know Taylor cares about 900 times in
college but like we're in ter matters to
me
I think he's a better receiver out of
the backfield and he's faster and Henry
is weird because he'll have long runs
where he's not fast and just no one
wants to hit him so I think Taylor gives
you he gives you a little bit more than
Henry does but I know people are gonna
be pissed and saying how high can he say
it's better I don't think he is right
now but he's better for your
I think if you're looking at these guys
you almost has to have to judge them
over the next five years what are we
gonna get we're gonna get Jonathan
Taylor and a rookie deal where he can
come in and like you know before with
DeAndre so he might be a top-10 rusher
in the NFL Derrick Henry has proven he
can also do that he's gonna cost you a
lot more money to be that rusher he's
gonna take up a lot of your cap so for
me over the next five years yeah give me
Jonathan Taylor almost over everybody
back I am with you all the way number 30
the Green Bay Packers if you listen to
us during NFL Combine week Matt had a
report that this team has been doing
work on the tight end class they've been
doing work on tight end free agents if
you listen to the free agency show
here's the kicker I think the Packers
are gonna have a new face at tight end
this year we will know a lot more after
free agency but when you look at the
draft right now I like Coke Ahmet here I
mean the top five receivers are gone and
I think commit in a scheme where Aaron
Jones had a phenomenal year running the
ball commit gives you a little more as a
blocker I shouldn't say a little more
compared to Jimmy Graham and Sternberg
he gives you nine hundred times more as
a blocker he's great in the red zone he
can work the seam I really just like the
fit here now if they go out and get an
Austin Hooper this probably isn't the
pick but once again this is this is as
high as commit can go and he he would be
a really really nice addition for Aaron
Rodgers says I don't want to say he
declines all players decline but you
really need to give him a big body
target you just can't throw Davante
Adams out there and say hey good luck
man yeah I love this pick it I would
have you know said receiver here but
with them gone commit it's a great pick
here and I think when you look at the
free agent class of tight ends we're
gonna see a couple get paid I would see
the Packers loading up on defense
through Fred you see filling those needs
middle linebacker safety wherever they
go and then drafting to fill out this
office number 31 my San Francisco 49ers
this is actually very tough here because
the receivers are gone I don't value any
safeties here and this it seems like
Emanuel Sanders is a free agent Ark
Armstead is free agent Jimmy Ward's a
free agent but one thing that gets
forgotten is that the corners outside of
Richard Sherman actually sucked this
year a Kelly Weatherspoon was
haribol and i Emanuel Mosley played
pretty well and I know they just picked
up they tendered him the option for the
exclusive rights for agent corner is a
pretty big need here and Jimmy Ward
played a lot of slot corner if you can't
bring him back
just give me Jeff Gladney because I know
he's gonna knock people out of the line
of scrimmage he can play man covered
something I don't know if you watch the
second half of Super Bowl the Niners
corners aren't very good at you so I
think finding someone who can match up
when you have to play teams with speed
at receiver which is all of them give me
Jeff Gladney and I know interior lines a
bigger need wide receivers a bigger need
but I think they have to address this
defense yeah I agree and I really like
Jeff Gladney I'm sitting here with pick
number 32 for the Chiefs and he was a
guy that I was considering I knew that I
was gonna have Jeff Gladney or Kenneth
Murray left and as a Chiefs fan that
made me very happy that they would have
one of those guys to choose from
so with you taking Jeff Gladney off the
board I'm gonna go with Kenneth Murray I
really like these linebackers I talked
about Patrick Queen earlier I think
there are three complete linebackers
they can play through the trash they can
drop in coverage they can run now I
would almost put them with even that you
know Devin Busch Devin white from last
year we've been very lucky these last
two drafts to have very good linebacker
play and the Kansas City Chiefs really
need it they need somebody that can
figure out they can stay on the field
all three downs take away the middle of
the field guard some of these tight ends
that are coming up with the Broncos with
Fant Waller with the Raiders you need a
guy like that and I think that Kenneth
Murray can be that dude
we are back it's time to do round two
cutter sorry man you should enter this I
thought I was on the clock never my
collar is up 33 something I was very
confused when we came back that you I
let you ride with it I figured you were
so excited to make the controversial
pick of Joe borough at number one you
wanted to find his pairing here at 33 if
you asked me this one a month ago or
even you know before the Senior Bowl I
would have been like no shot right now
33 Denzel Mims going to Cincinnati I'm
blown away guys I just didn't think he
was this athletic this is a rare
combination of size athleticism I've
always seen the catch radius on film
there's no doubt about
you know the matchup against Jeff
Gladney isn't it's a classic in this
year's draft class obviously the top
five receivers come off the board and
round one so when you're looking at this
receiver class for the Bengals it's
gonna be interesting how this shakes out
with a che green I like Tyler Boyd John
Ross is there I mean we'll see what he
does
that's why I didn't go with the KJ
Hamelin Jalen rhaegar although I expect
them to be better players than Ross I
think they'll still give him another
shot but Mims is a big bodied pass
catcher that unlike AJ Green who might
be there the next 1 to 3 years that Mims
can be a franchise cornerstone for Boro
yeah I like that a lot and I've been
leading the charge they need to go
receiver here I think linebackers
another area we'll see what they do in
free agency
number 34 the Colts in round 1 we had
them go Kayla Vaughn chase on I'm just
gonna stay in Baton Rouge grant Delpit I
think 34 might be a little early for
grant Dell but that could surprise some
people but just give me more playmakers
on defense for the Colts I know everyone
say oh the offense is the problem
I think getting those receivers healthy
it's gonna be a huge part of this so
load up you got like Costanzo for two
more years you've got some playmakers on
offense when they get back healthy if
you have a badass defense it's just a
lot of problems dump it and chase on or
two huge parts of that and we see them
pick again at 44 yeah I like that pick
and like you said grant Delpit falling
here a month ago I would have been very
surprised to see him going round to here
number 35 overall the Detroit Lions I'm
going with JK Dobbins here I think that
you need to give whoever this
quarterback is gonna be I'm assuming
Matt Stafford give him more weapons and
they have carry on Johnson in that
backfield but carry on hasn't been able
to stay healthy I think a guy like JK
Dobbins that can come in and share the
load or honestly probably just take all
the carries it's gonna really help this
often so you've got some really good
young receivers you took the tight end
Hawkinson last year offensive line isn't
terrible you've got some pieces there I
think a guy like JK Dobbins could come
in and have a very good rookie season
and help prepare this offense for their
future you pair him with a CUDA in the
first round Matt Stafford is not going
to be there forever
whoever this quarterback of the future
is going to be he can come in and say
alright I can hand the ball off to JK
Dobbins I've got some young talented
guys like Hawkinson and tied in and
you're set you're in place for a very
good push and a good rebuild if your
Detroit yeah Bob Quinn takes our running
back it seems like every single year so
even with Cary on Johnson there nothing
would shock me with the Lions and
running back 36 the New York Giants I'm
going safety here and I'm going Antoine
Winfield jr. one of the best playmakers
on the back end in this class the Giants
they have holes across the board on
defense we said on the free agency show
go get Byron Jones and man if you can
sign Byron Jones you draft Antoine
Winfield for the backend of your defense
you're developing DeAndre Baker at
corner now you're getting somewhere and
I think this is a team that will also be
active in adding a pass rusher in free
agency as well so the Giants need plays
they simply need a guy that can go on
the back backend make plays Winfield
junior has great hands he makes plays
the line of scrimmage tackles for a loss
and as a Blitzer and I just think this
is a really really good fit at a
position of need yeah I like this a lot
for them and like the last two picks for
you guys are just like that's just smart
team building like just go get good
football players because there's a lack
of that and Winfield that when he's
healthy matches up so well 37 the LA
Chargers they didn't take Jordan Love in
the first round I'll stick him in the
second round so this won't happen I just
want to say this won't happen he will
not all they're around it won't happen I
think he goes top ten but this is the
way the cookie crumbles when you're
doing a mock draft where no one really
loves the quarterback but you all know
he's gonna go early so Jordan love falls
here the Chargers would be doing
backflips it just again it I don't think
it's realistic but if this happens you
got to jump on it yeah yeah I don't
think he lasts till the second round
either but like you said that's the way
the cookie well last year we kept having
it like this kept happening to us last
year with Daniel Jones where it's like
someone will take him it just isn't
going to be any of us and I don't I
think we all like Jordan look better
than Daniel Jones I'm gonna put words
anyone's mouth but it seems that way but
it it's the same situation where you can
Noah guys going early but it's very hard
to find that fit yeah cuz it's one team
taking a risk on a quarterback that kind
of has some
questions and it's probably gonna be
somebody and if la like you said if
you're sitting there in the second round
I think that's a no-brainer pick for
them and I think they pull the trigger
I'm up number 38 overall the Carolina
Panthers the Panthers like we kind of
talked about maybe they're doing a
little bit of a rebuild themselves they
took Derek Brown in the first round
I'm gonna go corner here in the second
they've got Jackson there who's a great
speed guy they're probably going to lose
James Bradbury probably to New York so
I'm looking at corner I'm going with
Jalen Johnson out of Utah I like what he
can do I like the way that he plays he
can be aggressive with his hands but he
can also keep up with you with his feet
so I'm going jaylen Johnson a guy that I
probably would have considered at pic32
for the Chiefs or in that later part of
the first round he's there in the second
so I'm going with him at 38 overall to
the Carolina Panthers 39 the dolphins
this has become a bit of a fan favorite
not just this pic but more of the player
Kyle Duggar the do-it-all safety from d2
and I think Duggar man everywhere he
goes guys he just keeps on winning he
looks great in coverage at the Senior
Bowl he comes in to the combine and he's
just a great great athlete good size you
really wonder if he can play a
linebacker that's how big he is and how
well he moves and I think for the
Dolphins you're just looking Brian
Flores wants an identity on this defense
but you want somebody that can line up
with those mismatched players and I
think tugger can do that in the slot
against tight ends
he can play deep safety but he will come
down into the box and hit you so for the
Dolphins you're just looking for these
players that it can do a lot of
different things for you is you're
trying to repair up so many different
holes and I think the duggar rise
continues now into the top 40 here
Dolphins fans might not love this comp
but this can be the Patrick Chung for
Brian Flores like you guys just does a
little bit of everything and Patrick's
been there for like 11 years and he's
been a starter all 11 years for the
Patriots but that type of player I
absolutely love Kyle Duggar number 40
the Arizona Cardinals Melo had them go
wide receiver in round one I would love
to come back and go offensive line here
I personally after we had six tackles go
in the first round I just don't value
someone so you could have a little
bit of a reach on and I say Wilson you
could go into your offensive line with a
Damian Lewis or that's about it I'm
trying I'm just like someone else nope
that's actually about it or Simpson John
Simpson from Clemson but I'm gonna go to
the defense an area that I really would
like to see them get better at is the
interior defensive line Melo mentioned
in my earlier Chandler Jones is a hell
of a player they've got some speed on
that defense but they're missing someone
in the middle who can kind of wreak
havoc Marlin Davidson from Auburn fits
this defense very very well I have
concerns about him I wonder how much he
was really aided by the fact that Derek
Brown drew so much attention but we saw
this man at the Senior Bowl one day
there was all it took
he was phenomenal so I think David
saying it 40 is a much better bet than
you know David's in at 25 I think this
is a good value for him yeah I agree I
really like Marlin Davidson and what we
saw with him at the Senior Bowl I think
could even push him higher than 40
overall number 41 overall the Cleveland
Browns are selecting and in the first
round we went tackle obviously I think
the second biggest need for the Browns
is gonna be linebacker still especially
with Joe Schobert leaving in free agency
so I'm gonna go with Zack bond as a
linebacker slash edge rush type guy I
think that in this defense you could
probably play him all over the field and
they're gonna need probably a
replacement for Bernier I I really like
him I I think that he could even develop
into a guy that can play that middle
linebacker spot work off ball linebacker
but just keep him on the field somewhere
like he's ain't at Wisconsin he can get
after the quarterback I don't want to
say he's a poor man's Isaiah Simmons but
he is almost that gadgety player where
he can rush the quarterback he can do a
little bit in coverage and he can play
linebacker I think that fills a huge
role for what the Cleveland Browns need
42 Jacksonville this is their third pick
in the top 50 Melo
I know you gave them Patrick Queen at
linebacker with that second first
rounder I'm gonna continue the run on
defense here and go with AJ Terrell
there is this weird thing with Terrell
where he gets killed for struggling
against Jamar chase boobie
everyone except kam dance lair in
college football I don't know how that
one adds up but I really like this guy I
really do I think he was a good corner
for Clemson with length
I think he's tough and nasty I think he
could play man coverage so for
Jacksonville
I mean you traded Jalen Ramsey lost
pieces at linebacker they might trade
Yannick and Gok way they're gonna have
to reload this defense really
exclusively through the draft and I
think Terrell is quietly a very good
corner in this class that just because
of a poor national championship
performance has the wrong picture
painted of him
I like a.j Terrell a lot I do too every
time I was working on rankings today
because of draft 400 work and I say
every time I look at the rankings I move
him up and it's like be and even in my
notes I'll put things to myself like hey
remember how much you like him you don't
don't drop him like keep him up and
that's how I am with Terrell I really
like his game 43 the Chicago Bears this
is one of those Khalil Mac picks from
yes from the Raiders this yep there it
is they swap I'm back with you guys now
hi I'm earth this sticks a football
number 43 the Chicago Bears this pig is
from Las Vegas because of the Cologne
Mac trade although Jalen hurts here and
I know that might seem like a ridiculous
value on a quarterback that we've set at
it's probably third-round her that
doesn't matter because if you need a
quarterback value is gonna rise to the
top I look at this tier of quarterbacks
would would Jake from and Jacob Eason
and Jalen Hertz all the J's has a
quarterback in this class I would rather
have Jalen Hertz than those guys I don't
really go party with Jacob Eason
I'd rather Jake from married my daughter
I don't have Jalen hurts be my
quarterback you know like what are the
categories when you're looking I mean
he's such a great playmaker and he's
high character he's smart and the NFL's
moving finally to a league where to play
quarterback at a high level you either
have to be like Tom Brady smart or bill
to move around to make plays and I even
think the days of Tom Brady and Peyton
Manning's you know drew Brees type
quarterbacks is going away Jalen Hertz
ability to move off his spot make plays
it's not gonna be the prettiest [ __ ]
we've ever seen with his mechanics
that's getting better I would have to
roll the dice on Jalen Hurd's then roll
the dice on Jacob Eason or roll the dice
on Jake from and I don't want to seem
like I'm making this comp because I'm
not but this almost feels like Russell
Wilson when he was drafted like me he
moves around pretty good he's got an
okay arm he's really smart though
very charismatic leads the locker room
and then he falls to like the second
round in the third round and then he's
probably gonna roll in here to Chicago
take the starting job we're gonna look
back at it in two years right we really
over thought the fact that Alabama
wanted to run the ball with him all the
damn time Oklahoma he threw the ball
well so I like that pic and I think it's
just one that's gonna stick at 43 for
the Chicago Bears I'm up number 44 for
the Colts Colts fans got to be happy
with what we've done so far for them in
the very first round they took chase on
edge rush problems gone earlier in the
second round we gave them grant Delpit
staying with the LSU thing I think that
is just they're two of the best
defenders in the entire draft
Indianapolis gets both of them so I'm
going to go with a playmaker here I
don't think they know LSU not from LSU I
think they're all gone so far I don't
think they need a running back I like
what they have there so I'm gonna go
with the receiver they struggle to stay
healthy there and if you get too I
Hilton back healthy if you can get
Parris Campbell going and then you throw
in a guy like KJ hammer I think all
three of those guys can kind of be that
gadgety play together type though and
handler getting him the ball using him
on special teams letting him in Paris
Campbell kind of figure out each other
in this offense and also give your
quarterback some weapons if you are
gonna stay with BER set for another year
give him some more weapons so that he
can figure this out and you can figure
out is this a guy that we can win with
for a couple years or do we just need to
say yep we needed to tank for a guy like
Trevor Lawrence because we don't have it
at quarterback Tampa Bay Bucs back on
the clock and they got Justin Herbert in
the first round which means this team
still needs to find some offensive line
help especially if you're putting a
rookie quarterback out there I am giving
them the biggest human knot names Makai
Becton in this draft and that is Isiah
Wilson from Georgia who somehow just he
looks colossal guys this is
like the mountain in football it's
unreal but Isiah Wilson he's from here
in New York coming out of Brooklyn he
did not get a ton of play experience why
Georgia I think he only got to play for
two seasons so he's a little raw
especially in pass protection but you
can see the ceiling with this guy you
could see above-average starter
potential which is why I think he does
come off the board in the first two
rounds and for the Bucks
man they need to find a solution that
tackle I don't think it'll be in free
agency and if they are gonna plan to
draft a guy or even just sit back they
might watch all the tackles come off the
board they'll have to have a plan like
this in round two and of the next tier
guys it's really Isaiah Wilson and then
not much depending what you think of a
guy like Ezra Cleveland Ben barch it
really depends on that I like him the
best so far out of all those guys yeah I
do as well number 46 the Denver Broncos
I do think wide receivers a big need for
this team opposite Courtland Sutton give
him another playmate give drew Locke
another playmaker Brandon I you somehow
slips down the board here I will gladly
steal the yards after catch monster to
go to Courtland Sutton here yeah and as
the Chiefs fan I I don't want to see
them get more targets but it makes sense
there might have CJ Anderson a brand new
Guinness Draught yeah so yeah just guys
that I like no big deal
number 47 overall the Atlanta Falcons we
talked about Freeman earlier running
back I do think that he's gonna be a cap
casualty especially if you can get a guy
like Clyde Edwards to layer who is
probably just a better version of
Freeman they're gonna take him here at
pick number 47 overall I think it makes
too much sense to put him in this
offense he can catch the ball runs with
that low center of gravity I don't care
what his 40 time is he can run the
football probably come in and be a
Rookie of the Year candidate with the
Falcons alright last pick here before we
take a break the New York Jets how did I
get the Jets second-round pick here guys
yes good to me up we work this is how we
each got one of our favorite teams picks
guys this is tough they better they
better knock it out of the park and free
agency for offensive line because one
didn't fall to them in round one and
right here there's really no one to take
that would have a significant impact so
going on the edge here with Josh you che
listen they need pass-rush help it
almost goes under the radar because of
how bad the offensive line is here so
landing a guy in the edge that has
production at Michigan can get after the
quarterback especially if they lose
Jordan Jenkins in free agency is a
must-have for this defense pick number
49 overall the Pittsburgh Steelers
making their first election in 2020
draft I'm going to a quarterback in the
future Jacob Eason I think this is one
team that might be okay with a
quarterback who players from the pocket
a little bit can throw the ball down the
field vertical stretch game Jacob Eason
fits that and honestly I just wanted to
get him around too because I do feel
like he's gonna go here and his comp is
just it's almost Ben Roethlisberger like
to its you're hoping right
so number fifty overall the Chicago
Bears we talked about Jalen hurts
earlier we gave them them him I'm going
with another pass catching target I know
a lot of Bears fans want a tight end I'm
going with clay chase Claypool
I love his game I think that he's going
to come in and be a big difference maker
probably on special teams immediately
but also developing into just like a
slot tight in or maybe even an inline
tight in for the Chicago Bears just a
big pass catcher that can block I don't
care if he's lined up at tight end
receiver and cannot run whatever
position you want to play him at I mean
yeah Calvin Johnson type testing numbers
for Claypool
I think that's gonna skyrocket him into
the top 50 players 51 the Dallas Cowboys
they got to bring back a mari Cooper
Michael Gallup has really turned into a
nice player for them but I still like
adding it wide receiver here because of
the value I'm taking Jalen rhaegar the
speedster out of TCU yes he gained a
little weight and didn't run as well as
you'd hope in Indy but that play speed
is on film and for the Cowboys that get
dak a down field target that's a
beautiful set of wide receivers with
Amari gallop you could play Rieger and
rhaegar in the slot and just dominate
with that passing attack and of course
is he he'll Elliott in the backfield
I guess Dax not come Dez isn't coming
back in this scenario don't think so
Jerry's got to think about it take a
couple minutes hour another shower
number 52 the LA Rams their first pick
in this draft
I think Corner is a pretty big need for
them offensive line is where I would
love to go here but as you we've all
mentioned there aren't many in this spot
in the draft which points us to free
agency I think a lot of teams are gonna
overspend on the offensive line of free
agency so for the Rams I'm gonna go
corner with Noah a bit noggin II from
Auburn a lot of it been agony Thank You
5 1,100 pounds with very long arms the
biggest knock on him ball skills he had
no interceptions but lived around the
football on a very good Auburn defense I
think he fits this style we're gonna see
them change this year I expect a lot
more press man from this defense that's
what he can do yeah I'm up number 53 the
Philadelphia Eagles we gave them Justin
Jefferson in the first round I think the
second biggest need on this team or
maybe even the the biggest need is
Corner I'm gonna go with Trevon digs
here I really like his game I like his
athletic ability I think that he just
needs to learn the position a little bit
more and then you're gonna get a
shutdown corner with great size great
feet and the ability to lock in with any
receiver I mean the guys covering Stefon
Diggs
for almost his whole life so I think
he's got experience with some elite
level receivers 50 for the Buffalo Bills
Shaq Lawson is set to hit free agency
and we'll have to see how our friends
Brandon Beane Sean McDermott attacked
the pass rush here I do think they will
be aggressive in free agency they have
the cap space to do so but in the second
round keep loading up and go with
Bradley and I hear from Utah ultra
productive player showed some really
really great traits at the senior ball
he's not the most switched up a bendy
kind of guy but man he is really really
productive a good hands
finishes plays so for the bills keep
adding to that defensive line and get
someone that really could start from day
one in Bradley and I number 55 the
Atlanta Falcons and oh baby we got an
edge rusher run about to start here I'm
going Alton Robinson a name we have not
talked a lot about since the season
began we expected big things from the
Syracuse senior just did not happen this
year I still find myself going back
loving the traits he had a very very
good senior bowl week as well nine and a
half tackles for last year only four and
a half sacks I think that was a big
disappointment after what he had last
year with ten sacks but I still like his
game he's got the NFL sighs he's got FL
size yet if
traits he's just not he's not the
longest guy and I think he's gonna work
on his past Russ pass-rush
craft a little bit for the Hagins losing
big Beasley they need someone with some
speed some twitch on the other side yeah
I agree with you there Matt 56 overall
guess who's picking again it's the Miami
Dolphins
they have so many picks they also have
so many needs we've give them
quarterback tackle running back I think
we even gave them a safety earlier in
their I kind of look because there's so
many picks we did with Kyle Duggar I'm
gonna address the edge guys now finally
two I'm going Julia no Kawara I like his
fit in this defense almost immediately
athletic guy with good size I want to
see what he does at his pro day but I
really like him in the second round as
an edge rusher that can come in like
we've said before generate pressure to
the quarterback maybe it's not a lot of
sack numbers but it's generating that
pressure so that some of these other
guys can come clean up too I really like
him out of Notre Dame 57 the Texans we
know how badly they need pass-rush help
here and they also need corner help
there's really no one on the board that
I like for them continue in this edge
rusher this is now the fourth one in a
realm going curtis weaver melo you
talked about how a julia nakawara is
somebody that didn't have a lot of
production in college but the film is
really good
weaver did have a lot of production and
he doesn't have the same traits as a guy
like Julianne Kawara but Weaver is
somebody that just gets it done with
power I actually thought the combine
went a little better for him than I
originally expected with that lateral
ability especially that 7:03 cone is a
good sign for him but 13th at half sacks
at a Boise State once again this Texans
team not a lot of picks got to make the
best of them get a productive player and
Curtis Weaver I think with Weaver the
biggest questions were you know what
kind of shape was he gonna come how is
he gonna look because I think there were
times the Boise State he looked wrong
allotted but yeah he just looked you
look sloppy coming in at 6:00 to 265 did
bother me a little bit like I really
thought he would be a little bit lighter
than that and we didn't see him run so
there are there questions there but
Connors right the tape is fantastic
58 the Minnesota Vikings went offensive
tackle in round one I may go to a corner
in round two we've told you a billion
times they
Rhodes is probably on his last legs
they've missed on some pics here
I think corners a big need camera Dan
slurred did not run exceptionally well
to combine but my goodness can this man
play football I think when you look at
short area quickness it's their
instincts timing his ability to be
physical get between the receiver and
the ball it's all there for Kamla Dan
camera Dantzler so I think you'd be
fantastic here yeah I really like cam
Dan Salerno that the 40 time a lot of
people aren't happy with it but Connor
mentioned Dan Slayer earlier today as
the only guy that's been able to shut
down Jamar somehow somehow it happened
but it did so it's on the tape it's
there for real I saw it and so I really
am a fan of cam Dantzler still and the
Vikings of course need some kind of
cornerback help and somebody that can
stay out of trouble in that secondary
the Seahawks up again number 59 overall
Seahawks are another team that have a
lot of needs they were offensive line
with Ruiz can be that guard Center in
the first round I'm going with Raekwon
Davis out of Alabama I like his link
I like his ability we've mocked him and
I probably topped fifteen before but
coming out of Alabama we haven't seen a
lot of production his numbers have kind
of been falling and I think see how it
could be looking at a lot of turnover on
this defensive line losing guys in free
agency even if they bring back to Davey
on clowny I think that Raekwon Davis can
play in this defense play him as a three
Tech next to Poona if you lose Geron
Reed or maybe even play him at times on
the outside I know that he weighs in
over 300 pounds but he's got a lot of
athletic ability and a lot of length in
that frame that he can get after the
quarterback he could play against the
run and he can play almost every
technique on the d-line 60 the Baltimore
Ravens here they are a team that does
not have a lot of needs which is a very
nice position to be in I envy you
Baltimore and they are gonna go with
Lloyd cushion Barry here one of the
better centers in the draft and before
you get mad at me because I know they
have mascara I know he's a restricted
free agent unfortunately a mascara offer
also tore his ACL MCL PCL and dislocated
his kneecap so it's no guarantee he's
ready to go and start a training camp
I'd get yourself some insurance even if
he is he's an RFA
so you're giving yourself some insurance
a guy in Cushing Barry that's a good
backup and can maybe be your long-term
starter down the road
number 61 the Tennessee Titans another
team that has sneaky needs but we expect
them to fill a lot of these through
fraid you see one that probably will not
is that slot corner with Logan Ryan
being a free agent I'm no Damon Arnett
here I was very disappointed by his
combine performance not just the 40 just
in general I've been at times high and
low on Damon Arnett it really depends on
the week for him when you watch him play
being the number three corner at Ohio
State as a senior is a concern for me
even with how good Jeff Okuda and Sean
wait are you would expect his senior to
bump one of those guys probably Sean
Wade down but our net just kind of a
gadget guy but I think he can be a good
slot corner just solid physical he'll
tackle that's one thing Mike Vrabel is
gonna love about Damon Arnett he might
be the best tackling corner in this
class so anything he fits here at 61
yeah I like our net to and I do think he
can come in and be that slot corner
immediately maybe not the guy on the
outside but not everybody is and he does
what he does very well
number 62 overall the Green Bay Packers
we gave them that pax
pass catcher in the first round Cole
commit I'm going linebacker they might
lose a linebacker in free agency with
Blake Martinez
I think Malik Harrison is that
old-school thumper linebacker you want
somebody to come in fill a gap stop the
run it's Malik Harrison and he's
athletic I think he could use some help
in coverage Ohio State had a shitload of
linebackers they asked them to do
specific things and it worked for them I
really like Malik Harrison though if he
were on my team I love it so pick number
62 Packers fans be happy with the mock
draft you get a linebacker in the second
round that's very good 63 the Kansas
City Chiefs your Kansas City Chiefs this
pick is actually from the team they beat
in the Super Bowl so double whammy
Thanks just disre disrespectful sorry
Matt yeah that's alright you'll be fine
Justin Matt a bouquet here in round 2
really a gap shooting defensive lineman
for the chief somebody that can get you
know can generate a pass rush really
productive player while I am I think I
would make this pick with or without
Chris Jones to be honest with you I just
like the talent on the board now
most definitely make this fake if they
trade Chris Jones but I still feel
really really good about the player no
matter what as they look to get you know
a really nice rotation for their
defensive line next to Frank Clark yeah
and they're a team that's hard to figure
out Melo and I were talking earlier
today I was like they could go corner
into your office line linebacker D line
but if they went wide you still running
back wouldn't he be like it'd be okay it
wouldn't even shock me at all thing
right now
number 64 the last pick in this draft
the Seattle Seahawks this is from Kansas
City as part of that Frank Clark deal
I'm gonna go corner here this is much
higher than anyone else will have
stamina Gries big run I like him and I
know that you're gonna read rankings
that have this student the fourth or
fifth round I like Stanford Samuels I
just love the way he plays he is
physical he's smart and he was on a
god-awful Florida State team I have him
ranked 62 overall and when I was talking
to scouts this week they were like you
are on drugs this guy's a fourth-round
her don't give a [ __ ] I think he's a
good football player trust in my eyes
not theirs
what do you have him overall 6262
alright I got him in 96 but I like him
as well okay well we'll see who's right
no no I don't say like I like him at 96
and I go what the hell are you thinking
it's making me think maybe I need to go
back and watch a little bit more of him
I like him more than Damon Arnett when I
took a couple pics before yeah and I
think with corners here at the end
you're gonna start to look at me and I
need a corner I got a guy sitting there
knocking over all my board but [ __ ] it
I've got to take one plus I need one
this wasn't planned and and I know we're
running out of time but I also heard two
exciting Scout calls this week because
Draft 400 stuff and just trying to
bounce off trying a medical basic on a
lot of these guys but I heard that teams
do not like Neville Gallimore either
which we didn't have him in our round to
mock here which surprised me because I
we've talked a lot about him but Justin
mata bouquet going 63 no Neville
Gallimore yeah I like mata bouquet
better than gal more to be honest with
you
same-same so it's gonna be see me
interesting it's fun class I know that
and we're gonna talk a lot more about it
we'll be back Monday we'll be back
Wednesday we'll be back Friday and we've
got some good news coming for you guys
down the road so don't miss any shows
cuz you're not gonna want to miss it for
Connor from Melos Matt we'll talk to you
guys real soon